JANET RANKIN: The
lightning round
is a nice interactive technique
that I use in my class.
And what we do is
I divide the group
into usually two
teams, two sides,
and I have them face each other.
So you can have them face each
other in two parallel lines,
or you can have an inner
circle and an outer circle,
as long as one person is
facing only one other person.
And then you can
do it on a topic
similar to the debate where
there's really two sides
and you ask the one side to
take one side and the other side
to take another side.
But the difference with this is
that the communication is only
between the student
and the student
that he or she is
facing, and they only
have one or two minutes
for the interaction.
So one student gets to speak
for say, it's a minute,
and the other student gets
to respond for a minute.
And then after
that's over, I ask
one line to shift,
or one circle to take
a step to the right or the
left, and now each person
has a new partner
that they speak with.
Generally speaking,
if you had one row
be the pro and the other
row be the con, then
for the next iteration,
you would switch roles.
So there would be
the con and the pro.
The advantages of
this technique are
that the students get to hear
a lot of different opinions
from a lot of
different students.
The fact that it takes
only two minutes at most
for each interaction means that
you can do it several times,
four times, five times.
If you do it five times,
it's only about 10 minutes,
maybe 13 minutes with
some time to translate.
So it's a pretty quick exercise.
And by doing this
lightning round,
students can get many
different perspectives
from other students.
The other kind of question you
can ask with a lightning round
is you can ask a question, maybe
you give students a few minutes
beforehand to do a
calculation or to solve
a particular kind of problem.
And then you say, OK,
you have one minute
to explain how you did the
problem to your partner.
And your partner has one minute
to explain how he or she did
the problem to you.
And again, that lets students
see other students' approaches,
and it lets them think
about their own approach
in the context of the
other person's approach.
You also tell them
they're allowed
to change the way they
think about the problem,
or to think about the response,
based on what they've heard
in their previous pairing.
So it lets students
kind of iterate
and develop their opinions
kind of as they go.
A couple of disadvantages
of the technique
are that it's very, very noisy.
So students are speaking
with each other.
They're really only
about a foot apart,
and everyone is speaking
at the same time.
STUDENT: I originally
thought there
was going to be an
increase, but then I
learned that in the 1870's,
there was like, a mini ice age.
JANET RANKIN: So
depending on the class,
depending on the
personalities, depending
on the people in the
class, it may not
be such a great technique.
But the advantage is that
it really gets everybody up.
It gets everybody moving, even
people that are really shy.
There's virtually nobody that
will stand there for a minute
and not say anything.
Even people that
are extremely shy
are generally willing to
talk with one other person.
And since you
can't hear anything
about what's going
on in other groups
or even the instructor
can't hear what's going on,
it's a fairly safe
conversational situation.
So that is an advantage of it.
The thing I like
about it the most
is that it gets students up.
It gives them the opportunity
to formulate an argument
and to listen to the
argument of others
and then put their
opinion, or argument,
or answer in the context
of other answers.
And it lets them hear the
opinions and responses
of a lot of their peers in
a very short period of time.
After I finish the
lightning round,
I always give students a
minute, or two minutes,
three minutes to sort
of sit down and reflect
on the exercise,
what they learned,
if their answer changed, how
it changed, why it changed.
And then we usually do a
large group report out to say,
I thought this going in,
but I heard from so-and-so
and this is what I think now.
So we do a little
bit of a report out.
Also because of the fact that as
the instructor, since you can't
hear with students
are saying, you
want to know if there's some
big misconception that's
been propagated
during the activity,
and you would want
to address that.
So the report out
for that exercise
can be particularly important.